um hi everyone and welcome to like a
gentle intro to large language models
and their real world applications I'm a
software engineer I work on community
engineering serving and productionizing
models that are not anymore
I'm going to start off with a very
simple example to kind of get your
interviews about large language models
are and how easily interact with them on
a daily basis when you go to Google and
you got to search for something so you
try to understand how the city
Technologies work right like how does
City work and like
functionalities you go and type like
Siri and before even finishing your
entire second word simply predicting you
the next word right now there's a
competition going on between your
keyboard and Google to see which of
these is correctly what you're looking
for uh and then when you actually end up
searching for that query you get a
response that looks something like this
and you see like a small excerpt over
there that just kind of kind of what
your answer should be I'm saying what
I've actually work open the article is
just summarize right there
and the question uh I like to ask people
is the fact that when you click on that
you see this highlighted text that pops
up to you
um which part of this actually ends up
using the automatic models or analytic
in general uh so if you guys think it's
one can you raise your hand give me a
show no think that
and then three
all right so we don't have strong
conversation between like any of these
are largely uh using a lot of language
tasks so I'll tell you that all three
are actually using uh language
processing in some form or the other and
the first one is basically a form called
predictive text where it tries to say
um predict the next word right and this
is one of the Fairly common use cases
for it we had older Technologies and now
we have more modern more powerful
machine the system that actually focus
into much more accurate predictions to
what you're doing right
uh and the second part as well again is
flashing I'm supposed to think that part
generally ends up being a form of
genitive text that is a summary of like
looking size answer of what you're
looking for and in many ways it's going
to save your time
um and the last part again is the fact
that it highlights that specific text
and it gives you exactly what you're
looking for but points it not just to a
specific summary got a website that
actually contains those exact lines
uh and I'd argue there's a step in the
middle called 1.5 which is sort of the
most important and this is kind of the
foundation of how semantic search and
how Google search and a lot of these
search engines function nowadays
um so like I said autocompeting is
predicting the next World semantic
search is basically finding correct
articles of the correct content from a
huge apology of uh content and then text
summarization which distills that and
then actually question answering if you
uh look into semantic search it's
actually one of the deeper and more
well-seated parts of large language
models and their abilities to get you
the right content
uh and it's been around for a while the
term semantic search but the ability and
the power of it is growing more rapidly
as we get more and more powerful models
um another example about large language
model is capable of is response
selection if you try to write an email
and your uh sending it to someone when
they get that email they have options of
how to respond to it and you'll see
these liquid Niche summaries that come
in Gmail or any other email slide you've
seen a short concise and often pretty
accurate to what you should be doing
um so yeah these are the different areas
of applications of in Real Worlds for
language processing tasks and a lot of
these end up having some form of large
and smaller basis of them properties
and and to take a segue again just from
purely large language models and their
vanilla applications there are a bunch
of use cases where you end up taking
these models and you use them in
conjunction with more powerful models or
Technologies to build really powerful
applications uh one of them for example
is Vision if you look at image
captioning you see like really old
existing models back from 2015 and 2014
so you would have like a sentence
description of an image another example
would be visual question answering and
I'll dive into that later but think of
it as like you have an image you ask the
model a question it understands the
the intent and the direction of the
question and tries to answer it based on
what is understood so it's using like
some Vision Centric tasks and
information in conjunction to the
language model to kind of get you the
answer that you're looking for and the
last part is probably something that all
of you are more familiar with nowadays
because it's pretty much the high it's
image generation you give it a text
prompt and it generates a nice uh image
for you and it can be any form of image
you want it's very flexible it's uh
currently very trendy and you see a lot
of social media posts about it again
this OCR and UWI OCR is just language
because you can just recognize
characters without using actual language
and detect it but you get a really
robust language model you need to
understand uh
not just the exact characters themselves
but in conjunction what they mean uh so
you can even understand more complicated
pieces of text that aren't easily
readable like maybe a handwriting or so
on are there a bunch of other
applications but the one I'm focusing
currently on is captioning so let's look
at this image for example and look about
how it came back to that summary again
this is back from 2015 so like seven
years ago we were able to do this and at
that point of time this kind of blew my
mind because in my head I didn't think
this is possible for a machine to do as
a software engineer until I got to know
the power of deep learning and language
models in general so it says a group of
people are shopping at an outdoor market
and there are many vegetables at the
food stamp now obviously this might not
be what a human describes it to be but
it neatly captures what the exact
picture is and and to me that's great
power there are a bunch of applications
that can arise from that another really
cool example of this would not be just
understanding or capturing the image but
getting like a more deeper semantic
understanding of it and then being able
to interface with these language model
that understands it and have a
communication and a visual question
answer session with it right Flamingo
actually came out with this and
uh you'll see a picture of Barack Obama
he's a former president of the United
States
uh and then this is a sample
conversation that happens in the model
and I'm going to read it out after this
kind of time so this is a picture of
Barack Obama and he's the former
president of US that's what the model is
telling us and and that's great right
but clearly there's more going on in
this picture so let's let's prompt this
model let's urge you to give us more
information uh how many people are in
this picture uh it says you know there
are five people in this picture
and Nikki enough it actually didn't mess
up if you see the Reflections in there
but it captured that and and it was able
to say that there are five people and
their Reflections aren't necessarily
people which is great uh and then it
asks where is this picture taken it says
it's taken in a school which I'm not
sure if it's correct but I'd say school
isn't very far off the next question is
how many mirrors are there and it's able
to direct objects and even give you
answers to them right so it's counting
objects so here there are two mirrors in
there and uh what is the person standing
on if I asked a question like that to
you you'd say which person but he knows
what the center attention is and it's
going to say that the person is standing
on a wrong clearly that's not the person
that we're concerned about we're kind of
concerned about the other person on the
scale so we'll tell the model hey uh the
person standing on a scale and nobody's
like okay you're right so you ask it uh
that's not all I want to know what he's
doing and he says he's looking at a
scale great but now it's coming to the
part where this humor is there and he
was it obvious to me in the starting but
if you look closely into the picture
you'd see that Obama's foot is pressed
on the
scale and then uh it says it's on the
right side of this case if you
understand the relative position of it
as well even though this model was
instantly trying to do this task it's
able to generalize and understand the
intricacies of this uh and even
communicate with us activity and what is
the result of him putting his foot on
the right side of the scale this game
shows a higher weight and and to me that
that's funny right so uh is the person
who's still aware of it you're trying to
tell the model that okay get deeper into
that and the models are going to tell
you uh I think he's not aware of it did
you ask the murder like is this humor is
this funny why is this why people are
laughing and the motor is like I think
so so clearly the murder isn't perfectly
communicating what you wanted to but if
you urge General prompted you can get to
where you want it to be uh and these are
an emergent problem properties in large
image models where they might not
immediately do what you want them to but
if you prompt them if you like push them
in the right direction they can get to
where you need them to be
um and I'll talk about product
engineering more in the future but let's
talk about something that's really
trending right now in a generation there
are a bunch of models out there uh
stable diffusion darling image gen
they're actually taking prompts of
images text and convert that to
animation this is mind-blowing in itself
because
um it's even to understand not just the
implications of it but to get like a
visual image description of it and this
model isn't trained on a specific task
let's stay into like just look at text
and generate images right but if you
look at the examples over here you can
see government the Frog inserted into a
bunch of different movies and it's able
to get the aesthetic and styling of the
movie so if you look at the the one in
the top left it's inserting in Star Wars
and the one on the right it's Blade
Runner and you can see the neon feel of
it right like you're getting the Blade
Runner kind of uh Divide from it and
then you look at the one on the bottom
left and it's Matrix and you can clearly
see he's got like those uh Neo kind of
glasses on and he's he's uh feeling more
like he could be a part of the Matrix or
trying to escape it and the last one is
uh from Spirited Away so clearly these
models are able to capture more context
than than could probably do in this box
um another example that you probably
would interface with and Neo may not use
as often is when you're searching for
images on one of your Cloud platforms it
offers you the ability so this is on
Google photos
um one of the cool applications of it is
that it doesn't just look at the picture
and tag it immediately it does OCR as I
mentioned and then extracts The Elixir
part of it in the text and then tags
these images or abilities when you look
up and you add a Content it's able to
like get close semantic times to it and
populate them for you so you get all
these technique really well labeled
images just by searching for something
around there right uh and there's
obviously more going on down there
location and that metadata and all those
but you see the cost of it really lies
in the power of the language model and
the ability for it to capture this
information and create it in a form
that's uh indexable researchable uh on
the right again like
can't help which is about cats so I
can't sort of guessing that so like I
said there are a bunch of really cool
use cases of these large event models
and the applications of them in the real
world that we actually use on a
day-to-day basis and we aren't really
well aware of and to me that blows my
mind they become so ubiquitous
ubiquitous in our lives that we take
them for granted and they're getting
better and better so the possibilities
of what's going to come in the future is
endless
uh where else are these really used we
might not all use it but we definitely
thankful for it and you can see how it's
not just used in tagging or generation
it's used for translation as well and
it's used for like these really smart
virtual assistants that don't just
understand and your speech and convert
it to text but actually extract
information out of it and bring you
useful content and act on it based on
that so it's activating on intent it's
activating on your information is
activating another contents actually
brings you what you want and to me
that's that's really cool where they've
come in the last 10 years
um but what got them together
um say back in 2018 this is around the
time where I was in grad school I ended
up actually hearing about court and I
thought it's really fancy and then a
year later Google goes out and actually
productionizes it in one year it ships
out these revolutionary technology that
improves searches draft speed and to a
regular user maybe we didn't see the
difference as much but as you started
working on more complicated queries and
started looking for results you'd see
more and more of these results actually
end up being what you want and that's
mind-blowing right what changed in 20
years like receiving the same technology
for 20 years and then changed using a
large language model and boom so which
is a better so this is actually
productionized for 20 years the software
Engineers work on technology is a ways
to improve these and you see a
generation leave in a matter of one year
just by using a large number for me
that's that's my doing but before I
proceed let me give a huge thank you to
Jay who's actually preparing these
slides and he's given a talk similar to
this before uh at five later in London
we saw one of the folks at coher who
actually works and partners with people
outside he helps evangelize it talks
about all of these large magnetic models
he had a YouTube channel and he's pretty
active so you should feel free to follow
him and he's got great content out there
that you can use to wrap up on larger
models
language models uh I'll give you an
example of what we can do to get access
to these large language models and play
with them and get to know them so go
here is the company I work for we focus
ourselves on building NLP sdks and
toolkits that allow people to integrate
them to any pipeline without having
really strong understanding of NLP or or
machines that can run this kind of
predictions than trading so between
these models and get it out there for
you it's just a simple API but before I
allow you all to Simply let me actually
talk about why uh all of this is of any
important to anyone right apart from all
the applications you already saw uh some
of the use cases that we actually see
launched in the industry but ourselves
sometimes is that when we are talking to
these uh customer service people any
start a conversation
we don't immediately get a person
sometimes we get like this bot this EI
that actually waits for us to ask a
question and directs Us in the right way
so uh sometimes you're not even talking
to human entirely sometimes it's
entirely bought and it's able to
interface and have a full phase
conversation with you it's pretty
coherent and understands almost always
what you want to do so it's it's getting
intent it's getting what you want and
it's getting information to you out
there all of this is powered through and
it's underlying the arch language model
which uh in certain places is entirely
like stacks of technologies that combine
together to solve these problems
uh another really important part
especially because a lot of people are
coming online and probably have seen
this not just on on social media but in
other forms of the other is content
moderation
and you could use this in different
settings but I use social media as an
example large Vehicles content
moderation on on social media and other
platforms where you have like millions
and millions of users much harder and
they're not human interventable which
means that they need to have
Technologies and solutions and really
strong models that understand language
to be able to moderate and bring down
these uh content that are either toxic
neutral or just something that you don't
desire for that platform
so how do you actually distinguish or
get information out of these there are
different use cases but one of them
would be say a classifier and in general
a class pattern we used to say is this a
positive sample does this exhibit the
behavior I wanted to or is it a negative
sample is it a cat a dog or something
like that so it's basically
discriminating between two different
types of data and it's going to give you
a class label for it
another use case as I mentioned before
semantic search where you actually
search for something and you have like
huge repositive information and you try
to find what closely you resembles that
and and why is this not the same as just
a string lookup right like if I have a
search query on Google
why does Google notices run a simple
search for those exact words across
multiple websites and the answer to that
is semantics just because the document
contains the words you're looking for
doesn't mean it's what you want it
doesn't mean that it's talking about
what you're aiming to solve
um
an athlete is rank kind of got replaced
by poet and such a uh models like that
is text animation right so you've come
to a point where these models can
actually generate content that is very
similar or almost identical to what
humans could write and the quality of
these keeps getting better and better uh
we've seen models like GPT two three and
so on that actually
create entire blog posts and articles or
even scripts or movies that are very
believable if not 48 sometimes so let's
talk about classification first taking a
step back right I talked about how like
you can discriminate between two kinds
of text whether something is toxic or
non-toxic
but how is this done how do we get to
that how does the model understand what
it needs to do and what's the starting
point
um so you can fit in text to a model and
you can say that this is Class A Class B
kind of have it as a
structured problem uh training is a
supervised function and get this result
out right so I'd actually argue that in
the case of sentiment as I mentioned
before for toxicity there is a case
where you want to not just detect good
intent or bad intent but nutrient and I
think that's the difference between
Academy and Industry a lot of Industry
right now actually involves you add a
neutral or like a
non-activated form of this sentiment
large because language isn't always
emotionally charged and they can
generally focused on that isn't good or
bad and that's kind of it is easy to
evaluate and it's also a huge pain to
change all of these data sets between
purely for these cases
but yeah another really cool example is
that so you say you buy something for
Amazon or anything orders right and you
wanted to turn it before you do a return
you can go to the chat board and you can
say hey I want to return something right
so you might not even use the word
return you can just say something about
the fact that like the product I found
is 40 it doesn't have the battery That
was supposed to ship
so it will understand that you might
have a complaint with it and to try to
segregate this into categories of hey
like are you complaining about the
quality of the product right do you want
to return the product or are you saying
like he didn't reach your time right so
these different categories for uh
classification of returns and so on
to make sure other people argue and
feedback about it and get that
information and B I also want to return
it so this becomes like now a
multi-level classifier which is
different from uh having a multi
multiple classes this is more about the
fact that a single entity can have the
ability to belong to multiple sets and
the reason that I distinguish that
easily over here visually uh is by using
like those 3D buttons instead of check
boxes so in checkboxes you can select
multiple of them and they're all valid
answers but in really important you can
only select one of them
um another example is emails back a lot
of people can actually go down to your
email and open up your spark folder on
an email client and see like bunch of
emails are actually spreaded out for you
and sometimes you filter out really good
ones but almost always if it run the bad
words and and this is kind of a very
useful example of how it saves us time
from dealing with Spam or or people
trying to hack our emails
um again I mentioned about toxicity
classification but another really cool
example is chatbot intent aspect
classification I already talked about
the Amazon example but this doesn't just
limited to that think about having full
Village conversations with a teacher or
something similar to that and cannot get
answers to your problems you can you can
go into this field and like generate
this problem of fighting it for any use
case uh say you want to know information
about biodata you don't want to look at
the schedule you can actually have a
chat about rain on the entire data set
of like the entire talks and if you ask
you questions and then it will tell you
hey this talk is on ABC and so on which
is pretty cool
um
but we talked about classification right
and that's one really interesting use
case but what's also really fascinating
and probably more exciting to me is
representation which isn't just about
discriminating between two things but
also
kind of finding a way to encapsulate
this information that the model has into
a way that's digestible by other media
um and how do we really
encapsulate text right how does the
machine understand it
it looks like that and that's probably
useful for some kinds of use cases but
if you want to really get to the meaning
of that sentence that's not going to get
you anywhere and you can even go to
Unicode and capture it like way more
different types of things all the emojis
that you have on your keyboard out there
but it's not going to get you
um the two deeper inside of what the
language is exactly
so yeah like I said you can you can have
without language models you will have a
way to validate your password and that's
great but if you want to build something
really fancy you want to build
applications that Leverage The semantics
and language understanding and the
ability for
um you to get deeper meaning of these
texts you want to use large language
models and one of the common ways to do
that is to use the embeddings of these
models which I'll talk about in more
detail and then build things on top of
these embeddings
now what are embeddings uh well
embeddings are kind of a way for the
libraries model to encapsulate
information that it already has but in a
numerical form that can be used for or
even other models down the line
um so you can kind of have a vector
representation right an array of numbers
maybe like thousand or maybe four
thousand depending on how you train your
model but it it captures like in these
floating Point values that captured as
meaning
and you can see that how can these
numbers capture name and I'll get to
that in a bit but uh take my vote on it
then these models can actually
encapsulate data in those numbers
themselves
um
for example
um you can look at the embeddings of
these sentences and see one is similar
to the other right if one is similar to
the other it means that they're likely
talking about the same thing they have
some semantic similarity an example of
that would be you can ask the model or
you can ask someone how is it going and
you can ask them when you open or Hi how
are you when you realize that how high
are you
um sorry Hi how are you good morning
to this specific thing and you realize
that when you open is not really the
same question as I was going at least
not in the English language
um another's coming to a point right
like we get similarity when you get
certain things that are frozen meaning
to the other you can get to a point
where you're able to effectively
visualize these embeddings by reducing
them from thousands to maybe like two
Dimensions right and be able to like get
insights out of this an example of this
would be I could take positivity which
you've ever written yet the embeddings
of those and visualize them and you'd
see that some of those speeds you're
complaining about uh maybe like subway
train that you just missed or you're
complaining about the fact that there's
too much noise at avenues uh in here are
you complaining about how beautiful
Central Park is how you're really
missing it out because you're stuck in
your room because it's covered so all of
these things will be good clustered
differently and you would see them
drawing closer and closer to each other
if they have semantic meaning and that
is useful information
to actually get you to where you
want
um but how do you go about this right
how do you extract these data and where
to use this like I said you can you can
use these to create semantic classifiers
that actually taken like different
things extracted representations and
train like sentiment for it so you can
get like a positive negative or neutral
effect of it and you can do this very
easily with other non language large
language models and get decent
performance but if you really want to
capture complicated pieces of text and
get really highly performing classifier
you want to get a large package models
I've talked about it guys language
models but I want you to take a step
back and talk about the history of it so
like how is this done prior to large
language models and why are knowledge
language models important in the past
you use these scikit-learn uh
functions and modules or down vectorizer
or TF IDs which is basically a way to
say if a specific program has a higher
frequency is probably less important and
that's a way for you to understand which
of these terms have more meaning or what
context they're used in or how they are
benefited so obviously you can get a
vector representation by just using
these counts so they're directive
frequency and get that to uh be drained
forward or justification classified but
you get a very power performance in most
cases and in those cases I recommend
using a large language model to actually
extract these in weddings instead of
tfidaf or account vectorizer and then
pass them on to this model in fact you
can have tens of hundreds of thousands
of examples extract embedding with
really green very powerful classifiers
and in these cases these classifiers can
be like cycling or very simple logistic
regression classifiers that are actually
competition efficient but the more
complicated part of it is actually
understanding sentiment it's the model
actually does for you
so yeah so there are then maybe three
ways of building classified and this is
just one of them what are the other two
so this example where you give it
examples and you train it to be
classified by extracting in bearings is
commonly used by many uh many people in
the industry but it's just one of the
approaches
and let's go down to what the embeddings
are again
so Baseline embeddings for specific
model are really great but sometimes if
you train the classified purely on them
people I don't get you to where you want
to be even though the implementing
capture the somatic similarity and uh
they're pretty accurate to that what
they're not here to do is solve every
problem you have so you might want to
fine tune them with maybe a small amount
of data uh why I say this is because if
you look at the diagram of their their
like points on the left and points on
the right the points on the left are
talking about like Fast need on time and
you see that they have negative mean
right even though they're not talking
about the same thing they're not
obviously capturing what you want to
they have the context of time and like
some effect on it on the other
and then the other one on the right is
talking about the products that are sold
and catalogs and you see there is
semantic similarity there but what are
you trying to look for say you want to
look for whether or not someone is happy
or not happy with your product and
you're looking at reviews on on Amazon
or like maybe
responses you got on Instagram page when
you're setting a product up there so um
you give me examples of of this exact
situation and you're able to fine tune
it based on that which means that these
two orange dots that you actually want
to classify as bad problems that you
have versus like stuff that people are
actually happy about
we're able to find fine tuning for that
only fine-tune these embeddings the the
space the latent space or like the way
the model accepted the numbers it uses
to represent these models they actually
change and they look very different and
individualization kind of captured what
it is it's an example of how models
could on fine-tuning get you better
results and obviously uh even without
like like a strong argument for it you
can see how these are able to better
segregate the data into the ways that
the model can actually distinguish much
faster it's a very quality classifiers
so that that approach is called fine
tuning and it's ideally one of the best
ways to get you to
have the perfect or like highest quality
results for your users
but but yes yeah that's fine tuning
there is um embeddings but what if you
don't really have a lot of data what do
you do there and and what's like a
really cool property of large language
models that allows you to create
classifiers directly based on that
approach
um but I'm going to allude to that
because I want to build some uh interest
so let's let's talk about semantic
search let's let's get our brains active
in a different direction
um well there are basically two ways to
use language models for semantic search
and one is by looking at results and
ordering them differently so this is
like re-ranking or a way for you to say
that these results are more important
and more geared towards what the user is
looking for and the other results are so
you already order them that way and you
populate maybe the first piece of Google
is better more element results and the
last way it will like stuff that you
don't think is actually
uh and the last part is like tense
retrieval which is a form of having you
uh look at like archive documented
headings and you query for them
but you're not getting results that need
to be ranked you're finding the results
and ranking them as you do so like I
mentioned their similarity by looking at
these numbers and trying to find which
numbers are closer to the other so you
can use Lego science similarity your
mean Square distance to kind of get the
values that are closest to the one
you're looking for and say that this
semantically means something closer to
what the user said so they should be
ranked higher and you rank them based on
this
um
so uh if the customer for example asks a
question you can find out which is
closer to it and then use that to kind
of trigger the kind of response you get
back to the user so the person is asking
about say how much does a burger cost
you can just link up to your menu and
make them do the rest versus if they ask
for the opening hours maybe you can just
give them a summary of your hours and
some exceptions for the days so
um
back to it but I'm going to talk about
next Generation now because that's
important to the the last form of
classification and also a variety of
problems that result or help you solve
issues that aren't really obvious to
people
so what is text generation as I said
it's it's a form of having the model to
predict the next word or set of words or
tokens based on word is already seen so
you could get the model to predict
content probably based on nothing and
basically tell the model that go free
roam your world and just generate a
positive content without any uh prompt
without any hint of what to do
and we give you good results but you
ideally want to clear this model to
generate
content before uh use case and that can
be different information
for example as I said you could just
generate content based on a sentence
before and predict your sentence or
paragraph or you could get it to look at
content and summarize it which is really
cool uh or you could get into paraphrase
a specific paragraph So that you can use
it without getting caught for digit
result and I didn't recommend that uh
the last part obviously is really cool
it's also like a stack to information
and it's kind of similar to the example
I showed you before where uh when you
search Google you're able to like look
at Five results and get content inside
that but don't just send that page as a
result to the user but get the important
information and display that is user in
a short precise format
so then here here's how we get the last
form of classification it's future
classification where you give the model
maybe a couple of texts so for example
you give it a prompt of like
um oranges or color orange
lemons are called yellow
roses are colored and even black and the
model will protect red and that's how uh
this new short thing works and we don't
really train like a complicated
classifier but you prompt the model into
understanding what you're trying to do
and it predicts a class based on that
which is fascinating it's one of the
emerging properties of large language
models which allow you to do things that
you probably weren't able to do in the
past
um I've talked a lot about prompting and
I feel like I might have confused Jordan
to thinking that you're gonna have to
teach the model everything you need to
do but in one way in one sense it's kind
of right that you do need to tell the
model what you need because modern has
no idea and cannot read your mind so
prompting and product engineering is a
new paradigm where
in the way I think of it is
you Googled and tell the model what to
do but instead of writing python you do
it in English which is really cool
because you don't have to learn any
programming language you can just put
off the model and teach it to generate
the content that you like but you need
to follow a set of rules to get the best
quality performance out of it so um in
the examples that I've shared before I
also mentioned summary and one way to do
this and I'm not recommending this is
the best way to do it but one way to do
this like really quickly and without any
complication is to basically give it a
paragraph and say in summary comma and
ask you to predict the rest now
obviously because you said in summary
comma the model is understanding that
you want to summarize the content above
it and it gives you a fairly good
summary of it and I'm not going to argue
about what basis somebody good or bad
but it is workable and it's maybe not
the best approach but it gives you
something good and in many use cases it
might just be enough uh to do what you
want to do
but like I said um the model can
generate content when you prompted your
car in your mind and I think that's
coming to a point where I want to warn
people that not damaged models aren't
um
send it
so what they are effectively is they are
models of the capability we have narrow
intelligence in specific domains or have
the ability to get you the information
you want given that you engineer them
across them in the right direction this
question over here is from which address
Guide to the Galaxy and the answer uh
that we want is probably the question
what is the argument question of life
the universe and everything uh anybody
know the answer for this question
42 right well obviously the entire point
of Y2 was fact that it does not make
sense right this is not trained to
understand life and we've looked at a
bunch of data crunch numbers and did
something very similar to what we do
with our language models right we gave
it access to data we looked at a bunch
of data and it was able to understand a
lot of it but for questions like this
it's really not clear to answer those
questions for us
um I've talked about Ground Engineering
and I've talked about how we can get you
to generate any useful content but the
one thing that I would say is a pro tip
when you're generating content from
larger service models is to basically
generate multiple Generations
so that you get uh different responses
and then pick the best one out of that
but what does it mean to generate
multiple resources why does the model
not generate uh the same there's a
parameter called temperature that people
refer to the industry it's a way to kind
of tell your model about how random you
want your answer and one way to actually
get this result is by tuning that
parameter and saying that okay I want
like more Randomness on their standing
list and uh what that introduces is
basically some kind of noise so
get a noise or no noise or lesser noise
you tell the model that these little
Generations you want to make and
depending on the noise and like the
random that you introduced to it you can
actually get different content which
then brings me back to the point of life
this particular generation that I got
for this use case is created I can pass
this on to my user all this generation
is housed in attribute
um well if you look at a couple of
candidate outputs that the model
predicts one of them is uh gonna be
better than the other and the way to do
that is to basically get a likelihood
score and that's one of the outputs that
the model allows you to get it's uh
think of it as a way for you to say
which of this content has the most
likelihood of naturally occurring in
language according to the model's
perceptional which means that which of
this is actually most coherent and less
non-city
um
and then when you look at these
likelihood you can actually rank them
and and get the best of them right but
maybe in some use cases you don't want
to get the most
likelihood content because that's not
what you're looking for
um
see we talk about paraphrasing we talked
about summaries in this content if the
model takes the input content and this
generates the same thing as an output
right it's going to be coherent it's
going to have a high likeli score but
that's not what you want so you probably
need to think about it a little
differently you want the model to have
livelihood that is not very high but not
very low just in the sweet spot for you
to understand and get the exact parts
that you're looking for without forcing
the model to generate content that is
identical to what you want or completely
away from what you want and I feel like
this is something that you probably want
to experiment with and get closer to but
it's one of those ways for you to look
at what similarity is and how to get the
best content out of
because if you look at the first
generation and it's lousy and you quit
you're losing up
so yes there is a generation and
classification and there are a bunch of
data sets that actually allow models to
get really valuable data from it but
think of it like this you can generate
data right so if a large animation model
is there and you have a bunch of
examples you can actually get it to
generate more examples that would be
useful to get a lot more data to get
your classifier strained better
um and obviously there's inherent bias
that comes in and I want to warn people
that X models uh aren't away from buyers
that's because they're trained on
content they'll be written as humans so
human bias can make its way into these
models and effective classifications so
you might want to take certain steps to
avoid that from happening uh but it's
still a neat way for you to get more
data and augment your model performance
very easily and very sweet
um so for example there are problems
that actually generate content about
specific kind of people the specific
classes and these models can obviously
have in their biases so what's the right
way to do this why why do you want to
in one way babysit your monitorships out
there it's because it's not in many ways
generating model out of content other
models is is going to be done by noise
and Randomness and there's always this
randomness of it getting inherent or
negative bias that is from the data even
if you try to filter out all the data
from it right so you can tell me okay
then don't train on bad data right and
and I wish it was that easy I wish I was
it was that simple for us to listen
industry but there are two problems you
should take out all the bad data of the
internet and and presume that you know
the definition of battery doesn't have
like a method to say that this is good
and this is bad you can still have a lot
of last or loss of information so for
example if the model never see something
bad it never truly understand what is
code and what is bad and it's never able
to distinguish things like toxicity and
enzymatic meaning and so on so um it's
important for the model to see your data
just like us but then create an
understanding or being kind of previous
it or urged to distinguish or generate
things that are good
and then again we come back to
generation enzymatic search but
um think of having ways to generate
similar content or questions the
questions are already in existing
websites and augment that between better
models there's a model called T5 out
there that's really useful for uh
summarization and transfer and so on but
what also is really really geared
towards that probably some other models
like for the gpdr is the ability for it
to take a specific question and mold it
into something that's exactly like it
but slightly different and I know that
doesn't really make sense right so one
of the use cases I talk about is
summarization where you can take a model
and have a budget content coming into it
but it can summarize that content and
give you a response but keep the
semantic meaning of it right so it's
doing like that entire summarization in
one step but instead of taking like a
prompt game to engineer it it's prompted
prompt out right
um
we come back to uh similarity and
customization in a bit but when you're
looking at questions and getting
answered the specific document
systematic search another really good
way to do this is uh take a prompt for a
question that the user asks or a
document uh where he's asking a question
and then compare that question that is
being generated based on the document
to a bunch of generated questions
already existing so what this does
effectively is a way for you to
take a question a user asks or a bunch
of data on a website or document and so
on and get the closest question that's
already answered in your purpose
to put the question that is asked so
you're kind of mapping your question he
asks to a question you already have an
answer to and ranking it based on
likelihood and then getting uh the
answer to the user and this is great
right because effectively means that any
website can have its own q a bot without
a lot of maintains or overhead and
learning again how many data you have
um
but we've talked about like the ability
for the model to understand and express
information but we have really talked
about how the model is able to do it and
how you can effectively engineer this
model to maybe more visually describe or
more expressively describe what is uh
thought process is so I'll give you an
example let's let's make a model do a
little later now right and you can see
like well it's not trained to do math
but that's one of the emergent
properties right if you teach the model
a logic or a workflow you'll try to
mimic that workflow and try to do
something similar but instead of just
making it do math let's make it explain
the math that it's doing
so an example of this is CA Roger has
five tennis balls and he buys two kinds
of tennis balls each can has three
tennis balls how many does these balls
does he actually have right and that's
the product given you've also prompted
as the answer to 11. now let's add
another question so apart from the
problem that you've given you added a
question that you actually want the
model to predict the answer off so the
calculator has 23 apples if they use 20
to make lunch and I bought six more how
many apples they have
is
um and then we're just going to help on
actually explaining that before I dive
into the actual answer the model gave us
um one of the ways to do this and one of
the really Innovative Technologies to do
this was this model that actually did
scratch Pad prompting when you drained
the model on data that actually
explained it's worked through kind of
like a stat space
and the model was able to keep track of
these intermediate representation
computation or text to get to the final
answer so um
the one thing I'd want is the fact that
these models they don't have a very
great memory right so they live in
context and they pay attention to
certain details but if you want them to
pay attention to other containers and
express themselves you might want to ask
it to take it step by step uh and when
you're taking it step by step it will
predict something similar to this
um
if you start with the 23 apples and you
use 20 of them to make lunch please
subtract 20. you buy six months adding
six and then it breaks down the
calculation right but but apart from the
Chain of Thought this cash part uh is
actually pretty useful because it's able
to keep you like give you current tally
it says that okay we have no NC apples
in the starting we take away 20 so we
have three apples and we add six so the
nine I know what this allows the model
to do is kind of have like a a way to
talk to itself tell itself that hey
remember XYZ that happened two steps
back and this way of like building
memory under scratch based on the model
can actually help it solve complicated
problems and it wasn't able to solve
prior to this which I think is uh is
very fascinating but also extremely
powerful
let's let's talk about text processing
pipelines we talked about how the model
can do semantic search and and also
questions but what we haven't talked
about is like how this entire process
would work
um in a specific industry case right so
the customer say for example sends a
message and I've talked about this a
couple of times you're able to classify
it to be a return or not and then after
that you'll be able to classify okay
what's the person who's returning the
product happy with the product or not
and then you search for the FAQ and try
to find out like if the answer to the
problem is already seeing is answered by
the company or the website or reviews or
simulation in the past
manner
uh you basically do something called
semantic or grounded QA where instead of
just asking it an open-ended question
you ask it questions specifically here
to a website and you look at the results
of the website and then you take the
website's input result as a prompt and
make a prediction based on that so uh
think of it as question that maps to a
specific website you do semantic search
and get to a specific result but instead
of just throwing the result in the
user's face gear that result into a form
that answers the question better so
rewrite it in a way
and that's done by our tax generation
model but then give that outcome of the
user for example if I ask the question
like where is pi data happening uh in in
New York it could give me the entire
line about the particular conference in
particular 2 is happening on explicitly
it and this time etc etc but I don't
care about the extent which you will
distill down specific information I
required and give me that uh that night
maybe I want the address maybe I want uh
the name of the office or building that
is saying and I will give you just that
really cool
and I know we're running a little bit
early but I have a demo to show you also
let me get through the summary of
whatever we covered before I dive into
that demo
no okay but yeah
all right um
how many of you want to go for lunch do
we want to get question answers down
right now and then proceed to the demo
or
generation we talked about different
ways to build classifiers and how we can
use different settings and how they work
but also talked about embeddings how do
you uh look at the similarity way to
visualize them and get like a visual
understanding of what the model is
thinking and understanding we also
talked about input problems and how
models can generate text and how to
clear that text to what you want but
also get multiple generations and take
out the best quality of the same we we
talked about how both embedding models
and text models are able to do things
that are Beyond this thing or embeddings
but obviously or other models to do
these things and we talked about how
fine tuning actually gets us better
resolves and helps us get results gear
to a specific area that we're looking
for uh
and basically adapt those specific
domain
um and again I'd like to thank J for
slides or you can visit for you.ei to
actually go to a very neat playground or
any open right here but uh it's
effectively a way for you to go and play
around uh any of these use cases that I
talked about and get a good demo of us
and then maybe
yourself
um this is probably too small
so I gave it a prompt about here are the
things that I love to buy data
conference and after taking the audio
tokens and this is what it ended up
predicting I I like to find Collective
talks which is extremely beneficial for
The Binding background the fact that
there were a lot of beginner talks this
activity could easily talk to a lot of
people the diversity of talks and the
fact that I see a lot of talks in so
many different topics
yeah so uh thank you for the talk and I
will take questions
yeah I'll leave their own first take
pictures
all right any questions
[Music]
give it the Baseline model itself but
then give it more input data and it
automatically adjusts the weights of
these things and brings the content
farther away from each other the more
data you give this model to look at find
you more better
you can find it in the entire model you
can also find in the last years of it
there's new uh Technologies and
techniques to actually find different
additionally on top of the top of the
model uh and then like adapters or TP
approaches but the vanilla approach to
do it is basically fine tune the entire
model
uh that's the easiest to implement but
like might not always be scalable
any more questions
yes one of the best practices for for
this kind of models
um good question so actually focus on
Market serving and I've been working on
it myself the one thing I can tell you
about the fact that these models like I
say are large and then that's not an
understatement these can be millions and
billions of parameters
the best way to take these model is to
not run them at full Precision at
reduced Precision they take less compute
they are more faster but there's a
trade-off of quality uh and then beyond
that there are certain times when people
just jump into the largest possible
model out there and they think that's
going to solve their problem but that
might not necessarily be the is for many
use cases a smaller or a medium-sized
model which is still fairly large and
much cheaper you can actually get to the
results you want but then the last form
is actually there is a use complexity in
deploying these models out there
sometimes you can take up like really
busy uh gpus out there that are
expensive and and it's not scary for you
to always do that yourself which is one
of the reasons why people who have built
is the platform to like take the cost of
serving these models in a way of doing
it of users but if you want to do it
yourself they're like pointers out there
in the industry where you can actually
in a couple of lines of code and a
Docker image get out these modes and
serve them if you're talking about scale
that's a different problem scaling these
models is kind of complicated and I
don't think there are many companies out
there that solve the problem deploying
like billions of these models out there
and production users in loading agency
environments
any more questions
yes
yes uh can you specify exactly which
part I'm going to talk about uh
fine tuning for a great thing you're not
training the world
yes
yeah so so think about these these
existing orbitals we talked about as
like the ones we trained and we left
with the best baselines or the ones that
you can get out there in the industry
the budgeting models are actually up
there and these boots are available
these are referred to as base
model when you find in these models you
can again say like I said choose to find
different parts of these models attach
several layers on top of the model
defined unit or uh take like a distilled
version of this so like there's
something called digital board which
compresses the model down and and so on
but you can find a way to get these
models into a smaller compressible State
and then focus on serving just that now
what this does is a reduces the number
of parameters if you're distilling them
or it reduces the overall time to fine
tune by taking these B-side models and
just modifying the waves on top of that
or in one case also just ends up adding
an additional layer on top of the model
so you're not finding these extreme
model weights investing with that which
is fine doing an additional layer which
is what scalable way to find
uh
and then in terms of embedding models
it's a little harder to find in the
embedding model because you can find it
for a case uh one advice people have and
the way people do it in the industry is
to find you the embedding model for a
classification class so if you fine tune
the embeddings for a classification task
and interior the values for that
direction then you can use that from
then on
or did that answer your question for
example
yes all right is there any more
questions
no more questions
all right thank you everyone
[Applause]